so check it out I have like a slight
gambling problems
not wearing a shirt because he bet it
yeah yeah and is in like the furthest
away closet yep away from so his wife
doesn't care yeah yeah because he
already lost the house you have like a
slight gambling problem go go back go
back go back I mean there is no such
thing by the way as a slight game no not
really no
hey what up Chris and Matt let's check
it out I have like a slight gambling
problem
um gambling I probably made
something between forty and sixty
thousand dollars in the last two years
online gambling
and the swings are up and down obviously
you know but losers obviously pays the
bills I mean that's a lot of money
um up more than I'm down and I probably
need to stop because when the swings are
low it affects everything yeah so acid
drunk uh what do you guys think should I
just cut it out and just take my job is
what it is and you know I make like 100
Grand a year yeah I mean is he okay with
that or should I continue to push and I
hope that it yeah you know the swings go
up
let me know thanks ah yes get out of
that bro that sounds like a [__]
problem waiting to happen so I mean it
is a problem when
you're up
okay when you're gambling and you're you
go way up which this guy obviously did
and then you go way down but you're
still technically up it's two things
that you realize one is that
you know you're playing a losing game
and you know you need to stop but at no
time is the impulse to bet more and get
that high back stronger than after you
lose winnings not you lose your money
but when winnings go away the urge to
get that one back to reattane that high
is so strong stronger than at any other
time and for all of those reasons you
should absolutely do everything you can
100 to stop now yeah because you're
gonna end up yeah and it's good it's
harder to stop the longer you do it I
feel like addiction you know it's like
I I would honestly
I would try to look I would try to have
you tried to stop before that's the
thing that I think that you should you
should think about have you tried to
stop before because if you have tried to
stop before and you didn't then that's
straight up addiction you know if like
you know the lows are so bad and you
can't stop even though you want to like
that's the definition of addiction so
you gotta try and somehow get some help
actually
um because gambling addiction is [__]
brutal dude uh it'll ruin your life I
mean I know some people here who are or
gamblers and it's just they've ruined
ruined their lives so
um yeah uh I would say stop honestly my
heartfelt responses stop because also
dude
I understand everybody's struggling and
it's hard to make money but if you're
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
that's a fine living like I mean
it's impossible but like you know
wherever you live like that's a fine
living dude it's not like you're making
000 a year to where you're like I gotta
do something yeah that's the thing like
you're gonna [__] your life up dude that
the whole reason why you're making this
video is because you know that there
might be a problem so if there might be
a problem then there is a problem just
it's like when you think somebody might
be gay and you're and you're like
realize you're like oh no no actually if
I'm even thinking that he's definitely
smoked some polls you know what I'm
saying so I mean not a necessary analogy
though you know what I mean yeah it is
though you know because it's actually
clearer with the gambling it is because
of the money thing but honestly if
you sucking polls was money you'd you
know you maybe think differently about
it you'd be like oh is he gay oh wait
the fact that I'm thinking that he's
definitely smoke some poles right so
smoke some poles yeah I do think I do
think that you should stop I think you
should stop
especially since you kind of are [__]
making you have a job dude you also lost
your shirt literally I mean that is an
expression yeah
symbolically it's very funny that you
called in with you yeah dude exactly you
lost your shirt literally and you're
gonna lose your shirt financially if you
keep betting yeah I'm telling you I get
it why you want to keep going more than
you did even when you first started
really way up this is this is not
complicated it's not confusing you're a
very people don't like to hear this all
the time but what you're experiencing is
actually
extremely typical
at this juncture you start to realize I
gotta stop or else it's going to get
really really bad that's why you're
asking and
it's all all things are pointing to you
got to stop right now
the big thing for me is if you tried to
stop before and you couldn't then you
guys what if he hasn't tried to stop
before it wouldn't lessen the amount he
needs he needs to stop still I know that
but I'm just saying that's a huge
wake-up call into where you know the
cycle has started and you're [__] yeah
but yeah it's easier to nip it in the
bud per se which sounds like it's
already too late for that but yeah I
don't know you haven't lost your [__]
nothing will feel worse than when you
lose money that you needed you haven't
done that yet save yourself the trouble
um
interesting it's it's the worst feeling
is that it
you you like to gamble or what oh yeah
but you have a gambling problem no I
don't do it anymore oh you used to yeah
but not not anymore yeah no not anymore
no I used to do it like you should do it
with what like baseball yeah like
baseball betting yeah but they're not
legal right like it's all legal [__] I
would do legal yeah so what would you
mean not like that oh yeah that's a lot
of money
I mean that is like 50 60 Grand yeah he
lost or was what like was betting at one
time no I don't have a [__]
betting to me gambling is just not
something that I have any desire to do
I don't know why it's just I mean it's
almost never about money for people
people for whom it's about money usually
do pretty well because that's they're
colder about it and they're like well
I'm not gonna do that that's not gonna
make me money
emotional gamblers are the people who
get ruined yeah because it doesn't
matter yeah it's the what is the biggest
head [__] for gambling addicts is that
it's not the high of a win right it's
the high of a low that you're right
right that's that's the most losing pain
you can imagine it's the chaos yeah yeah
it's the possibility of the low you feel
more comfortable in chaos so much is on
the line and you're just like it's just
the most literally Stakes are higher
than anything could possibly be
uh so people get a high from that and
it's the worst [__] thing to get a
high from
mm-hmm
okay well I hope you get some help I'm a
[__] it's good I've seen a video in a
while ago about gambling addiction oh
yeah well I was shirtless and as you can
see I got that shirt back there we go
all right no but uh I made that video
long before I submitted it I had some
friends that are fans of yours that were
like submitted it'll be on the show and
I was like all right I've submitted
before I probably won't be yeah here you
are sure everyone submitted a lot of
videos and then it was on Father's Day
and I was like [__] I need to rectify
this
so
between the time I actually recorded
that video and now this is Spence months
I have started a company with my friend
and I'm making a quarter million dollars
a year roughly wow and I haven't gambled
and gambling wasn't
really about money more than it was
about maybe
I was drinking so I'm going to poker
online and I would drink and get home
and get on my phone and like yeah put
200 bucks on time yeah sometimes win
like five grand or lose it or whatever
keep going keep going you know how it is
I do but um to run this company and be
successful as we are I had to put
drinking on the back burner with that
the urge and the need to play poker
online or to to gamble has is is
diminished completely I have no urge I
don't care
um
I've been addicted to multiple things
historically with different drugs and
stuff and I knew that alcohol was a
substitution in the gambling on top of
that was another one and removing the
drinking and just being hard-pressed
about removing it took away that like
potential loss of money with gambling
and stuff like that so I'm good just so
you know but to answer questions Chris
yes I did try to stop when I was
drinking and I couldn't stop gambling or
drinking so it took the measures of the
initial thing to stop and know Matt I
didn't bet 50 or 60 000 like you thought
in the last video I said that I had made
forty to sixty thousand dollars
uh profit and two years playing poker I
probably bet 10 grand over the course of
two years and made 60 Grand so it was
like
good but sometimes the swings would be
like 800 or a thousand or two thousand I
wouldn't have money for what I needed so
yes Chris I have lost money that I've
needed right but that's all done now and
I'm in a place where my family's fed
everything's good I have no need I have
extra money no need to ask for more
money on gambling and no need to drink
yeah so I think I'm in a place now where
maybe I'm fortunate or maybe I just have
a good head on my shoulders to walk away
from it but this one as you know cool
your advice was spot on and I'm good
thanks buddy thank you guys you know
what yeah just uh
you know uh stay awake and don't get too
comfortable but I will say though we
were just talking about this man like so
weird that uh addiction it just
permeates into other stuff if you don't
keep yourself in check you know like if
you have that is very true yeah if you
have a gambling addiction and then you
get get you you you just stop gambling
and you don't like do the recovery work
it could you know morph into a drinking
or uh or or sex or online or porn or
whatever it is
um blasting hookers in an Alleyway
whatever the the thing is you know what
I mean yeah
um but yeah that that is uh really
um
you got to get to the root of it which I
you know I I always think you know it's
just about what happened to you and when
you were younger and what you got you
didn't get what you needed and and
you're using these things to cope and
some are not so healthy and gambling is
not so healthy and drinking is not so
healthy
um but yeah I I uh that's good dude you
got your shirt back and that's great and
it sounds like this guy's super
successful it sounds like yeah when I
was in rehab man everybody also had
addictions with other [__] too it was
like and I mean I'm talking about like
you know there were people in there for
what they thought was a sex addiction
that they which which was but then they
realized that it was and you know this
guy's one guy's addicted to uh violence
like there was a guy was addicted to
violence and there was a guy who's
addicted to like you know these
intrusive thoughts of you know I was in
rehab and one time the guy a guy said to
me uh
um you ever get like thoughts about like
killing people and I was like no no no
no you know and he was like yeah he's
like I've always had a fantasy of just
like holding somebody's head underwater
in a sink and like just and like just
killing them that way and I was like huh
oh my God I was like huh that's
interesting thing to bring up somebody
you don't know extremely I just I just
[__] too much but yeah that's I mean he
he
um
oh I knew him really well because it was
I was there for a while yeah yeah yeah
yeah but um and I was like what is it
about that and he was like just the
intimacy of like them almost being able
to get out but they can't and I was like
that's that's what makes me upset about
it yeah no [__] not also if I told you
what he did for a living you'd be
shocked I'll tell you off air okay but
it's unbelievable you're like oh
you're out there you guys are out there
yeah maybe I don't want to know yeah
well I'll let it I'll let it I'm gonna
tell you no matter what so addiction is
it's very uh pervasive right so there
you go it's like uh spilled water it'll
always find the crack you know make sure
you don't spill the water Bruce Lee
addiction is like spilled all the time
made him English at the end they just
get something
[Music]
forever
hello